hit me with the national anthem
real quick know that so i could talk
over this
get up you [ __ ] it's monday
the 30th whatever the [ __ ] it is of june
enough is enough already for three
months we've been living in [ __ ]
misery confusion we're broke
we're hungry we want [ __ ] answers
stop blaming china
stop it stay in your house move out of
that [ __ ] apartment
but most importantly social distance and
most importantly besides that
this is a crucial [ __ ] situation and
some years are not happy
put your [ __ ] mask on you [ __ ]
maggot [ __ ]
let me tell you something you think i
like putting a [ __ ] mask on
i don't like putting the mask on i gotta
smell my own breath
50 years of rotten teeth and [ __ ]
and
nicholas [ __ ] breath and [ __ ] nose
hairs
i don't want smelling the [ __ ] breath
either but you have to do it why
because we're trying to keep each other
alive how can we be so [ __ ] selfish
you know what you want to go to the bar
go [ __ ] yourself
go to the liquor store buy a bottle like
every other american
and go outside and get three or four of
your friends and get [ __ ] up
no more [ __ ] parties no more
get-togethers
i don't want to see no black chicks
twinking with your ass up and down
they told you you can't eat ass and here
you are spreading those [ __ ] germs
up in the air i feel bad for midgets
you [ __ ] filthy [ __ ] animals so do
me one favor whether you agree or
disagree
when you're home when you're scratching
your balls listen i wouldn't put a mask
on either
i fought it and i could smell the fart
through the [ __ ] mask so if i could
fart
and smell it through the mask outside at
the park
that means you can maybe get a little
corona vibe no
you can't get the corona virus what i'm
telling you is
it's a public [ __ ] nuisance now
pretty soon
people are gonna get stuck getting hit
in the head with [ __ ] karate elbows
and [ __ ]
keep your mask on fourth of july is
coming do you want to be [ __ ] caught
up in the fourth of july
where's the music where's the meal
bubble started again
where's the music we're americans we got
to [ __ ] join in now
and enough is enough put on your [ __ ]
mask
it's not self-respect it's not respect
for us
it's starting to be respect for
ourselves
i wear a map put it on more i want to
hear more i'm getting fired up here
don't make me [ __ ] get a bottle rock
and cut in the nap
and make it chase different dresses at
the [ __ ]
you understand me get that mask put it
on
shut your [ __ ] mouth you [ __ ]
little animals in miami you [ __ ]
jungle spanish people down there you got
you should wear
masses day one when i came from cuba
they put a mask and goggles on me that's
how contagious i was all right
so go [ __ ] yourself don't let me break
out the goggles
you [ __ ] immigrant [ __ ] you're lucky
you're here
put on a [ __ ] mask it's a [ __ ]
right
and everybody else you [ __ ] white
people that think you're better than
everybody
because you pay taxes and you [ __ ]
drive up a prius
so what go [ __ ] yourself put on your
mask
black people they're trying to kill us
put on your mask
if it ain't a [ __ ] cop it's a bullet
now it's some chinese doing a laboratory
trying to kill you
and mexicans first of all if three is
over 200
pounds i don't want to say it together
every time i see seven fat mexicans
covered is coming it took out a family
down in orange county
if you're seven that made mexicans and
you're heavy knock it off
invite three skinny cousins who just got
here and ran the three miles
no more than four fat mexicans can get
together
and that's cubans salvadorans you puerto
ricans too you're not excluded
you have black and you have spanish you
you guys
that they roll the dice down there in
puerto rico put your [ __ ] mask on
social distance and have a little
[ __ ] respect
you see a line [ __ ] six feet 10 feet
put on your mask i don't enjoy it either
look at me i look like a [ __ ]
i look like i just got out the [ __ ]
uh sucking 300 dicks this is what you
look like when they throw you out
what happened to him they ran a train
through him last night at the gay bar
with 300 dicks i don't like wearing a
mask
does it say in american constitution no
but
right now as americans what's going on
and the numbers in florida texas
arizona and california wear your [ __ ]
mask
it's monday go out there and be a
[ __ ] champion
the church of what's happening now
thanks you i want to thank eleanor
kerrigan
i want to thank [ __ ] lee lee leland
and i want to thank you guys for all the
support
of what's going on in each other's lives
you need
comedy i got the [ __ ] answer you
understand me
but it all starts with the mask i don't
give a [ __ ] you're gonna hate me for
this
but as part of the church us we gotta be
marines in this [ __ ]
we put on our mask have a great week
have a great monday god bless you
take this [ __ ] mealy get this
[ __ ] mask off me